yo is Texas open carry yeah yeah yeah
yeah do you cuz you know like we're in
California where they make it extremely
difficult to like protect
yourself and uh you know there's good
things and bad things about that
obviously there there's a terrible
school shooting that happened in Texas
in new day I was there that's see that
you know I'm Frontline for all that I
was that was a heartbreaking situation
yeah yeah they rest in peace man um I am
like typically a liberal guy but I do
feel like our our countryes move so past
like ever changing the gun culture this
is just who we are like we are the
United States like I think that there
should be like obvious um background
checks like very common sense things but
I just wonder for you like do you feel
like in Texas certain [__] doesn't
happen as often because people think
twice about so it's the give and the
curse right it's the give and the curse
people think twice one cuz [__] the
person you thinking of going may have
exactly what you have so you you're not
really trying to right feel that you
know what I'm saying you you you have
that but then it's
like the curse is damn you Empower some
of the the goofies that just do stupid
[__] that don't stand on principle or
nothing and been and accidentally hurt a
child or something else so you know it's
the it's the gift and the curse with it
man which is like it's almost like here
like the gift and the curse California
is like you know there's not as much
like I guess it's not as easy to just go
to a Walmart and buy AR-15 and go shoot
up a [__] your workplace or a school
it's very hard to do that the curse is
you might get ran up on and there really
like like it's active I'm sure you seen
the smash and grabs and people in the
bay get bipped every [__] day like
it's it's wild like so it's kind of like
it's kind of like you got to pick your
poys in a little bit and it's
unfortunate but this is America cuz you
ain't never going to get rid of the guns
n no no matter what there's too many of
them too much big business no man
but believe it or not you just you have
to I've learned to adapt to my
environment but I'm going to tell you
one thing that really really got to me
right I was one day cuz I like my son
Houston you know he's um
13 I expose him to the game yeah like I
he's he's going to have both smarts he
can be a square and a street kid at the
same time just so he
know what to do what not to do and if I
expose it to him no child can come key
him up and excite him to go do no crash
dummy [__] cuz it popson already showed
him y so um I was like man you know what
[__] it let's let's just go to the gun
range right but in my mind it's like
damn I don't want people sitting here
whining cuz he young man I went in there
it was kids seven to 8 years old all the
way up this the um this place super
super pack yeah but my point of saying
that is people are already preparing to
and they're already adapting to their
their environment and and you never know
I mean shit's getting it can get real
and the world is getting real right now
in general mhm yeah now I I twister does
uh a good job in uh Chicago he has
classes so you know it's crazy I told
him he going to have to come I told him
we were well we ended up doing trade day
so we didn't get around to it then I
just had my listening party in Chicago
he came out
um shout out to him Raul but yeah I told
him yeah he going to have to train me to
make sure I can be a sharpshooter I'm
I'm going to take some time yeah he's
really good at like he's training like
people how to properly own a weapon how
to prop like like you know what I'm
saying like cuz at the end of the day
like that's something that I think in
the black community isn't taught you
know what I'm saying you got to realize
man [__] from where we come from back in
the G we used to think to hold a gun
sideway that you not hitting none of we
used to think it was Goofy for people to
be like that but [__] no that's you got
to have your aim yeah yeah so yeah and a
lot of people's lives probably got saved
because it was held the wrong way to be
that too yeah yeah that's what's up man